the lore surrounding the darksaber is
first introduced in the Clone Wars in
Star Wars Rebels the blade made its
live-action debut in the Mandalorian
where it's shown to be in the possession
of moff Gideon at the end of season one
Gideon later uses the weapon in a battle
with ninjarin who successfully subdues
the Imperial warlord in the season 2
finale din's possession of the darksaber
becomes a dilemma for fellow Mandalorian
vocaton Crees as Gideon reminds the two
of them that the darksaber is now
rightfully dims and must be won in
combat in order to legitimize bokuton's
Mandalorian rule the Mandalorian only
makes the rule more confusing when din
loses the darksaber briefly during
season three the creature that takes it
is later defeated by Bo Katan and then
claims that this is enough of a reason
to confirm that the darksaber now
belongs to her however long before any
of this Obi-Wan Kenobi defeated the
Mandalorian previousla then owner of the
darksaber in a duel this defeat should
have made Kenobi the rightful wielder of
the darksaber all along during Maul's
time with the blade he's also defeated
by Darth Sidious making the whole
lineage of who actually deserves the
darksaber quite confusing